well big news for the unlv men's
basketball program kevin kruger
introduced his head coach to the runner
rebels earlier today
he has history with the program and
confidence in succeeding in vegas
i'm not sure if there's one specific
moment that there might be where you
you kind of wake up and realize like all
right i can do this uh
but i'm extremely confident
and that my experiences as a coach and
a player uh for six years after college
combined with the the
five years in college uh have prepared
me for this and
so going forward i am confident um that
that we can get it done
we can get it done eight news now's
kevin martin joins us live outside the
thomas and mack with much more hey kevin
well hey chris a fresh start with a
familiar face for the unlv men's
basketball program as you mentioned
kevin kruger named the
new head coach of the running rebels
today and after he spent the last two
seasons
as an assistant under head coach t.j
altelbergen we all know kevin is very
familiar with this program of course
as a player he played one year of unlv
under for during 2006 and seven
season that produced a mountain west
championship and a run to the sweet 16.
earlier today we caught up with another
player who was a part of that
sweet 16 run curtis terry he knows kevin
better than most and thinks it was an
excellent hire
i think what you see with kevin is what
you get i think some people don't think
he's got
the greatest or most forthcoming
outgoing personality but
they're definitely wrong kevin just
plays everything close to the vest and
especially
in his position now i think he's going
to be more vocal obviously
he's going to be looked to as the leader
just like he was in that 2007 locker
room
to where he was the point guard he was
able to rally all of all of us players
get us in position to go after the same
goal and he's just got that innate
ability to lead guys
and to get things done and i think
that's always good not just when you're
a point guard on the basketball
court but especially when you're a coach
in the locker room
exciting times for the running rebels no
doubt
for now reporting live outside of the
thomas and matt kemmie martin 8 sports
now